ubisoft has just released a trailer for
the division mobile game they announced
that they were working on this quite
some time ago but since then nothing has
been mentioned
well now we have something to work with
as well as some supporting information
giving an overview of what we are to
expect
first i'll play the trailer and then
i'll run through the detail of what the
division resurgence is all about
[Music]
[Music]
a few weeks
that's how long it took for civilization
to collapse
[Music]
but when society falls we rise we are
agents of the division and our orders
are simple
save what remains
street by street we fought to reclaim
manhattan
we fought to protect the innocent
to rekindle hope
but the fight is far from over
[Music]
they call themselves
and they're not alone
[Music]
the division resurgence will be a
free-to-play third-person shooter rpg it
will be offering the same aaa experience
of the division 1 and 2 but on mobile
however this won't simply be a port this
will be an independent division game in
its own right featuring a new
perspective on the story and the events
that have taken place as well as new
classes enemy factions and other content
it will be set in the same post-crisis
america after a virus outbreak has
created chaos and the quick collapse of
the government
like the other games the player will be
a part of the strategic homeland
division as an agent whose job it is to
restore the peace protect the innocent
and secure a better future
resurgence will feature a vast open
world that can be played either solo or
co-op through a variety of pve
activities including story missions and
world activities
the ability to loot collect mod and
upgrade a wide variety of gear and
weapons
the choice between specializations with
unique gadgets abilities and signature
weapons to help further build towards
your preferred style of play
and finally a whole new storyline
suitable for both newcomers and veterans
of the franchise
agents will be a part of the first wave
of division agents and will be shown a
new perspective of the events around the
division one and two
summing up the division resurgence is a
mobile third person luda shooter set in
an open world and based around the same
events that we've experienced from the
division one and two yet is a unique
story in its own right
i'm not really a mobile gamer but from
what i'm seeing here i'm actually more
excited for this than i thought it'd be
obviously we still need to see some
gameplay and having seen a lot of these
initial announcement trailers we know
there's gonna be a lot more information
to come but just the fact that we're
getting a new angle on the story this
could answer a lot of questions
especially around the early days
i'm not expecting hugely in-depth
updates on the law but who knows i've
been surprised before anyway that's all
i have for now if there are any other
updates i'll let you know soon cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay